grave concern about the mounting
allegations of sexual violence and
called for swift and rigorous
investigations to ensure accountability
as a central aspect of deterrence
prevention and non-repetition
the failure to acknowledge and
investigate past atrocities
is the surest sign that violations will
continue unabated
all the warning signs are flashing red
and yet
essential civilian infrastructure has
been reduced to rubble and ruin
gender-based violence and reproductive
health services are least available just
when they are needed most
we do not need hard data for a scaled up
humanitarian response
we do not need hard data for all parties
to ensure zero tolerance for sexual
violence
the harrowing personal testimonies and
pictures seen around the world including
of rape at gunpoint and rape in front of
family members
are a call to action
the report before us today surfaces
painful human stories all of which cry
out for justice and redress
in northern ethiopia
a young woman was taken to an eritrean
defense forces camp where 27 soldiers
raped her as a result of which she
contracted hiv
an elderly visually impaired woman was
shot by soldiers after being detained
for three days while her daughter was
raped by members of the ethiopian
national defense forces in an adjacent
room
an adolescent boy was raped in himura
who later committed suicide
there's also the case of a woman and two
girls whose discarded bodies were found
days after their kidnapping and rape by
armed elements in the central african
republic where sexual violence has
doubled over the past year particularly
against displaced populations who are at
risk of being forgotten victims of a
forgotten war
likewise the plight of over 900 000
rohingya refugees in cox's bazar
bangladesh has become a crisis within a
crisis following the military takeover
of myanmar by the tatmodal
this year's report includes the tragic
case of two women subjected to gang rape
by tatmador soldiers in qin state
resulting in unwanted pregnancies in
both cases
there is also the case of a woman
allegedly raped at gunpoint by an
officer of the puntland police force in
somalia a context where abduction
rape and forced marriage are rampant
while legislative reform to address
these crimes has been stalled since
2018. in colombia cases of sexual
violence committed against women
ex-combatants and members of their
families were also documented
in afghanistan professional women
including in the security sector have
been targeted for their work to address
sexual violence with a female police
officer who was eight months pregnant
brutally tortured and killed in goa
province
thousands of civilians abducted by daesh
in iraq and syria between 2014 and 2017
remain in captivity including victims of
forced marriage and sexual slavery
in yemen
harmful social norms exacerbated by
seven years of armed conflict can result
in a victim being killed for reporting
rape which persists in detention
facilities and displacement settings
in each of these contexts we see the
emboldening effects of impunity
indeed the gap between commitments and
compliance
resolutions and reality
is evident on every page of the annual
report
over the past year
sexual
sexual violence continued to be
committed as a tactic of war torture
terrorism and political repression
the report covers 18 country situations
and documents
3293 unverified cases of
conflict-related sexual violence
committed in 2021 representing a
significant increase of some 800 cases
compared with 2020.
once again the highest number of
incidents was recorded in the democratic
republic of the congo with 1016 cases
the vast majority of incidents targeted
women and girls 97
83 cases were recorded against men and
boys with the majority occurring in
detention settings
12 verified cases were fined found to
target lgbtqi individuals
the report demonstrates how intersecting
forms of inequality based on ethnic
identity political affiliation age
disability sexual orientation and gender
identity income and migratory status
increase the risk faced by diverse
individuals in a context of historical
power imbalances which are structural
and systemic
while the report conveys the severity of
verified incidents
no report can capture the full scale and
prevalence of this chronically
underreported historically hidden crime
indeed survivors continue to be silenced
by trauma pain and despair as well as by
stigma insecurity and the poor city of
service provision
there is a relationship between the
individual silence
and the official silence
survivors cannot be expected to denounce
what the state itself denies
when the perpetrators walk free the
survivors
walk in fear carrying the burden of
ostracism and shame
the central inside of this year's report
is the need to foster a protective
environment that inhibits sexual
violence in the first instance and
enables safe reporting and response
these are not isolated incidents
they do not occur in a vacuum
today we know more than ever before
about the security dynamics that cause
these crimes to occur and recur
namely mass population displacement
collapsed rule of law decimated
infrastructure and institutions
rising violent extremism and hostilities
wage in proximity to civilian population
centers
it is also starkly evident across the
world that lawlessness and impunity are
tantamount to license to rape
we are aware of the visible drivers such
as arms proliferation
and the invisible drivers such as
gender-based discrimination
we know the context in which sexual
violence is concentrated namely in
displacement detention at checkpoints on
military bases
and in rural areas where women undertake
livelihood activities
and we know that
socio-economically marginalized women in
areas
beyond the reach of law institutions
are at great greatest risk
what is this
what is this
may i continue mr president
yes
i think if if we could just request
everyone to put their phones i think
that was an amber
alert uh warning but uh srsg please
continue thank you
prosecution
mr president is also a form of
prevention
and can help to convert a century's old
culture of impunity for these crimes
into a culture of deterrence whereas
impunity normalizes violence
justice reinforces global norms
it is time to move from visibility to
accountability and to ensure that
today's documentation translates into
tomorrow's prosecutions
the prohibition on sexual violence is
clear and categorical
yet norms have no power unless they are
known
every member of this council
can lead the way in reflecting that
prohibition
in their military manuals
international humanitarian law
dissemination and training
codes of conduct and military
disciplinary measures at all levels of
the chain of command
we have said for several years in this
chamber that sexual violence is
preventable not inevitable
it is time now to make accountability
inevitable
survivors must be seen by their
societies as the holders of whites that
will be respected and enforced
and societies must realize that the only
shame of rape is in committing
commanding or condoning it
in 2021 four encouraging developments to
place in terms of transitional justice
first in guatemala five former members
of the paramilitary group the civil
self-defense patrols were convicted and
sentenced for crimes of sexual violence
committed against indigenous maya archie
women in the 1980s
secondly in iraq the council of
representatives adopted the yezidi
survivor's law which provides support to
victims of dice atrocities
thirdly the inter-american court of
human rights issued a ruling that found
the state responsible for violations of
the rights of colombian journalist mrs
jeannette bedoya lima following her
two-decade quest for justice for
abduction and sexual abuse
yesterday i was pleased to announce mrs
bedoya's appointment as one of my
mandate's global champions for the
prevention of conflict-related sexual
violence fourth under the auspices of
universal jurisdiction a former official
of the syrian general intelligence
service anwar ah was convicted by uh by
the ohio regional court in koblenz
germany for crimes against humanity
including sexual violence committed in
2011 and 2012.
each year we report three or four
landmark judgments against the backdrop
of thousands of un-verified cases that
meet the elements of international
crimes
accordingly i regret to note that the
few emblematic cases of justice
delivered are still the exception that
proved the rule of justice denied
in june 2021 my office launched model
legislative provisions and guidance on
the investigation and prosecution of
conflict-related
sexual violence
which aims to ensure
that the national legislation
comprehensively criminalizes all forms
of sexual violence and protects all
individuals at risk
this guidance support implementation of
security council resolution 24 67 of
2019 which calls on member states
to strengthen legislation and enhance
investigation and prosecution of sexual
violence in order to deliver justice
that is accessible empowering and
ultimately transformative in line with
the survivor centered approach
yet accountability processes world
critical
or no substitute for compliance with
international norms in the first
instance
this year's report lists 49 parties
credibly suspected of committing or
being responsible for patterns of sexual
violence in situations of the agenda of
the council
over 70 percent are persistent
perpetrators having appeared in the list
for five or more years without taking
remedial or corrective action
it is critical mr president to cohere
the practice of listing suspected
perpetrators and the practice of
imposing targeted and graduated measures
by sanctions committees to improve
compliance
leveraging the credible threat of
sanctions
can change the calculation of parties to
conflict that operate in the on the
assumption that rape is cost free or
even profitable in the political economy
of war in which women and girls are
trafficked traded and sold
eight sanctions regimes now include
sexual violence as part of their
designation criteria
in 2021 the 1970 committee on libya
listed the de facto manager of the
notorious nasser
detention center for abusers including
sexual violence
excellencies distinguished members of
the security council
in terms of the way forward the report
recommends targeted action to reinforce
structural prevention
through
political and diplomatic engagements to
address sexual violence in ceasefire and
peace agreements
the use of early warning indicators of
sexual violence to inform monitoring
threat analysis and early response
curtailing the flow of small arms and
light weapons
gender responsive justice and security
sector reform including vetting
training codes of conduct zero tolerance
policies and effective prosecutions
amplifying the voices of survivors and
affected communities and supporting
women's human rights defenders as well
as victims and witnesses
justice peace and security are
inextricably linked
collaboration between this council and
the peace building commission can
advance gender responsive accountability
and reconciliation processes which
address crimes of sexual violence as
part of the consolidation of peace
we must deliver justice not just law in
communities as well as courtrooms and
ensure that reparations reach survivors
to help them rebuild shattered lives and
livelihoods
it is critical that member states
reinforce the architecture established
by this council through resolution 1888
including the team of experts on the
rule of law and sexual violence in
conflict that works to strengthen
institutional safeguards against
impunity the inter-agency coordination
network u.n action against sexual
violence in conflict and women's
protection advisors whose timely
deployment to the field is vital for
timely reporting and response
we must marshal a level of resolve and
resources equal to the scale of the
challenge including by replenishing the
conflict-related sexual violence
multi-partner trust fund that supports
our work
our special report on women and girls
who become pregnant as a result of
sexual violence in conflict and children
born of sexual violence in conflict
circulated in january
also sets out a platform of legal policy
and operational recommendations
including reforming discriminatory
nationality laws and practices
i look forward to the special report
being debated by the council later this
year
excellencies the u.n charter was born of
war
to chart the path to peace
no amount of protection or assistance is
a substitute for peace
as a wise woman once said
you can no more win a war than an
earthquake
wars are indeed unwinnable
and yet their social and economic
aftershocks
affect us all
throughout history human progress has
been interrupted by plagues wars and
authoritarian rule
issues we thought had been consigned to
the ash heap of history remain in our
daily headlines
we cannot choose the times we live in we
can only choose how we respond
we must not rest until every survivor
every civilian can sleep under the cover
of justice
there is no place
in the modern world for gender apartheid
for strong men in place of strong
institutions or for medieval wars of
looting page and rape
women's rights are not western rights
they are human rights and they are
universal in times of war
and peace
prevention is the best form of
protection including the prevention of
conflict itself
we must rise to the challenge of our
times inaction is not an option thank
you mr president
um
i
wish to thank uh mr miller patton for a
very extensive
and uh detailed report
and if i could just make a request
for my
role as chair of this particular meeting
if you could please
ensure we have this is a very important
subject
and these testimonies particularly from
some of our survivors and in accordance
with due respect i would ask you once
again to please check your phones so
that we can then proceed with the
proceedings with that
it's my great
honor to now give the floor to miss
nadia murad the floor is yours
thank you mr president thank you as well
to ambassador woodward and to the united
kingdom
for organizing this important debate as
one of your signature events
and for inviting me to grieve today
ladies
gentlemen
and dear friends
we are gathered
at a moment of global instability
a moment
shaped by pandemic
war
and a climate crisis
in times like this
issues that affect women and girls
issues like conflict-related sexual
violence
tend to be pushed aside
as though
they are somehow secondary to the real
issues
but the truth is these are precisely the
moments
when protecting
supporting
and investing in women and girls
should be
our priorities
for every setback our societies face
women and girls are forced
10 steps back
this is particularly true
in times of conflict
history shows that whenever armed
conflict
erupts anywhere in the world
rape and brutality
follow we are seeing this
in ukraine as we speak
with reports of sexual violence
that should alarm us all
sexual violence is not a side effect of
conflict
it is a tactic of war as old as time
groups like isis understand
that destabilizing effect of
gender-based violence
and so must we
isis began targeting my yzd community in
2014.
thousands of yezidis
were massacred
others fled on foot
facing
thirst starvation
and blustering temperatures
in addition to the murders
isis captured more than six thousand
yazidi women and children
women and girls like me my nieces and my
sisters were sold and raped
those of us who survived were considered
lucky
but the nightmare
continues
even now eight years later
for more than 2
800 women and children
who are still living in captivity and
sexual violence at the hands of isis
we are here today
to discuss accountability
not only in the aftermath of
conflict-related sexual violence
but importantly as a tool
to prevent such violence from occurring
in the first place
in particular
these are
there is three aspects of accountability
i would like to highlight
justice
support for survivors
and a commitment
to gender equity
in the long term
the pursuit of justice is one of the
most visible forms of accountability
last year a german court
convicted an isis member of genocide
it was the first time
this had ever happened anywhere in the
world
this historic verdict is an important
step
but standing before you today my
question is what next
isis led a systemic campaign of sexual
violence to destroy yazidi women
and the yezidi community
the united nation
the united nations has condemned their
actions as genocide
unitad has collected reims of evidence
documenting the atrocities isis
committed against women and girls
and other tourist groups and oppressive
regimes have watched as isis members
openly brag about enslaving yazidi women
and
girls
while facing few if any
consequences on the world stage
as survivors of sexual violence
it is not easy for us to tell our
stories
but we do it to prevent what happened to
us from happening to others
we are called brave
but the courage we really want to see
is from leaders
in a position to do something
whether they are
heads of state
member states here at the un
or
corporate leaders
we need
more than moral
outrage
we need action
to those of you assembled in this
chamber
now it's your moment to put isis on
trials for genocide and sexual violence
send the case to the international
criminal court
or establish a hybrid court by treaty
to prosecute isis crimes
in the meantime
other nations should follow germany's
example
and use the principle of universal
jurisdiction
to try war criminals for the atrocities
they commit
including sexual violence
these trials must proceed with
transparency for survivors
who deserve their day in court
what message it will send if you let
perpetrators of sexual violence continue
to enjoy immunity
if you want to establish the turns
if you want to assure yazidi women and
survivors
everywhere that you stand with us
do not delay justice anymore
we have the evidence all we need is the
political will
accountability means that those who
perpetrate violence
should face consequences for their
but it cannot stop there
victims are not to blame for sexual
violence
yet
too often we are left
to piece our lives back together on our
own
abandoned by the governments and the
international communities
that felt in their mandate to protect
the basic human rights of all
people survivors need solidarity and
tangible support
to empower them
and provide a path to recovery
reparations and recognition are an
essential part of justice
that is why i have co-founded the global
survivors fund with my friend and
colleague dr denis mukwege
to provide interim reparations to
survivors of conflict-related sexual
violence
after all
to survivors reparations are not some
theoretical idea or a
topic for legal debate
they are the difference between going
hungry and having enough food to put on
the table
between sustaining lifelong injuries
and accessing
reproductive health care
between being cast out of our
communities
and being able
to put a roof over our heads
through this project
we want survivors to know that we stand
with them and they are not alone
eight years after isis genocide
survivors who returned to sinjar
are still struggling to recover in the
face of political disputes between
baghdad and erbil
with militia groups
vying for control of our homeland
the u.n security council should send a
special envoy to end the suffering of
yezidis in iraq
member states have a moral
responsibility
not to abandon
genocide survivors
this brings me to my third point
every time a new conflict
every time we see a new conflict there
is an outpouring of thoughts and prayer
but as i know from personal experience
a few days or even a week in the news
cycle does nothing to address
the systemic challenges women
face
this is true from iraq to ethiopia
to the democratic republic of congo
to ukraine
to conflict zones everywhere
it is not enough to talk about
accountability
and prevention in times of crisis
we need long-term commitments to
advancing global gender equity
because gender equity
is key to democracy
that means
combating gender bias and stereotypes
everywhere they occur
in homes and families as well as in our
education system
and it means recognizing that what is
true in times
of conflict is true in times of peace
if we want strong
stable communities we must listen to
women
to be very clear
when i say listen to women i do not mean
this in some abstract way
i mean that policy makers
should
leave the halls of power and go out into
affected communities and ask women what
they need
one solution will not work for everyone
throughout the world different
socioeconomic and political
circumstances impact women's rights
compounding factors such as race
religion
class
access to health care
education and employment
require different solutions
survivors know best
what they need to heal and recover
so why not ask them
at nadia's initiative the organization i
founded we see
every day
that the most effective work is
community-led
survivor-centered and takes a holistic
approach
the work that is being done
to help survivors must be
done hand in hand with them
it is not just
the act of listening
that matters
how you listen
the way you communicate with survivors
and what you do with the information you
collect
all of these things matter too
documenting sexual violence is crucial
for accountability and prevention
but too often survivors who speak out
face shame
stigma and lack of transparency
about how our testimonies will or will
not be used
or the likely outcomes
that is why
i look forward to joining lord ahmed
tomorrow to officially announce the
murad code
a set of guidelines intended
intended to change
norms around how
journalists
investigators
and anyone tasked
with documenting and investigating
conflict-related sexual violence
interacts with survivors
these guidelines were shaped by feedback
from survivors around the globe
and aim to promote greater respect
understanding transparency
and
healing in conclusion
accountability can be a crucial
component of prevention
but only if it includes meaningful
justice
the services and support
survivors need
and the ultimate goal of advancing
global gender equity
each of you
in this room
has the power to make this a reality
only if you choose to act
everywhere i go i met survivors of
sexual violence
who are bravely telling their stories in
the face of stigma shame and even
physical danger
if women who have
suffered such immense laws and
incredible pain
can find the strength
to not only rebuild our lives
but help our families
communities and entire
countries
surely the rest of the world can find
the strength to take meaningful steps to
end sexual violence in conflict
as survivors
we look to you
the leaders in this room
to act with the same courage we have
shown survivors do not want pity
we want justice
thank you mr president
thank you i thank on behalf of all of us
i miss nadia murad for her deep insights
and her continuing courage
and strength on this important issue
thank you miss murad for your briefing
it's now my honor to invite and give the
floor to miss
mariana
goodly the floor is yours
thank you
mr president excellencies civil society
colleagues
my name is mariana karkoutly and i'm a
co-founder of
a membership-based organization
of women lawyers and legal practitioners
advocating for accountability in syria
thank you for the opportunity to deliver
this statement today
mr president
let me start by saying that what drove
me to study law was not love of the law
but the experience of injustice
while studying law under a dictatorship
did not teach me much
witnessing women in syria fighting for
their rights did
accountability the theme of this open
debate is a difficult word to say in the
syrian context
we have experienced all sorts of
atrocities for over a decade with more
than 350 000 people killed tens of
thousands arbitrarily detained or
disappeared
nearly 13 million displaced and another
14 million in need of humanitarian
assistance
parties to the conflict have violated
international human rights and
humanitarian law
used chemical weapons and committed acts
that amount to war crimes and crimes
against humanity
government forces and armed groups
continue to murder torture and use
sexual and gender-based violence against
civilians as a matter of policy
yet
despite discussing syria for more than a
decade
this council has failed to take actions
to hold perpetrators accountable
the syrian government has systematically
violated not on the international law
but many of the security council's own
resolutions
meanwhile
members of this council
has blocked urgent actions on syria
shielded the syrian regime from
accountability and vetoed resolutions on
humanitarian assistance and
investigation investigating the use of
chemical weapons against civilians 16
times
my statement today will focus on three
issues
the use of sexual violence against women
entrenched gender discrimination in
syria and next steps from the
international community to ensure
accountability
as documented by the un commission of
inquiry on syria
sexual and gender-based violence has
been used against civilians during
ground operations
at checkpoints and in detention across
the country since 2011
primarily by government forces and
associated militia but also other armed
groups it has been called a devastating
and pervasive feature of the syrian
conflict
and part of a widespread and systematic
attack against civilians amounting to
crimes against humanity
this violence continues as we speak
i have worked as an independent
investigator with the support of the
center for justice and accountability
since 2020 on case building against
members of the assad regime responsible
for crimes against civilians
to date we have documented 54
testimonies including of survivors of
sexual violence
these are just some of the hundreds that
have been documented out of tens of
thousands of survivors
over the last decade at least 150 50 000
people in syria are estimated to have
been arbitrarily arrested detained or
disappeared
at least 9 700 women still are
these women lawyers journalists
activists and others have been detained
for opposing the regime or often to
punish or threaten male relatives who
have
in places of detention
sexual violence is used to humiliate
them to punish them for rebelling and to
force confessions
women in detention have been subject to
all kinds of sexual violence including
rape
torture
sexual harassment electric shocks
directed at genital areas intimate
searches
forced abortions and forced nudity
survivors of rape and sexual violence in
detention estimated to number in the
thousands have largely been unable to
report these crimes for fear of
marginalization or further retaliation
discrimination and violence against
women and girls who have been detained
or who have faced sexual violence has
resulted in abandonment divorce
so-called honor killings and suicide
the syrian regime has taken advantage of
this
they knew that by targeting women in
this way they were in fact targeting
their communities as a whole
this is why arresting and detaining
women
leaving their families with no
information about their fate has been a
key tool used to suppress syrian descent
since 2011
the systematic occurrence of these
crimes across the country provides
reasonable grounds to assert that the
regime has weaponized gender-based
violence as a matter of state policy
the syrian regime's actions have been
possible because of a corrupt legal
system and entrenched discrimination
against women and girls in syria which
impacts their access to housing land
property rights custody of their
children as well as their protection
for instance
laws in syria do not criminalize sexual
or gender-based violence against women
or marital rape
syrian women cannot pass their
nationality to their children
and even where laws have changed social
practices have not
furthermore sexual and gender-based
violence against women does not end
inside syria but continues in the camps
settlements and cities throughout the
region where millions of syrian refugees
face discrimination poverty and lack of
access to health care and education
all while experiencing pressure to
return to a country that is not yet safe
syrians are desperate for justice after
more than a decade of war
domestic accountability is impossible as
long as the assad regime remains in
power
the universal jurisdiction cases
currently being pursued against suspects
for crimes committed in syria while
positive
have also had limits including
how fear of retaliation for reporting to
local authorities and the trauma and
stigmatization of survivors of sexual
violence impact the ability and
willingness of victims to come forward
mr president
syrians can no longer wait for justice
we encourage all you and member states
to continue to pursue accountability
under universal jurisdiction
but we are also looking to you the
security council for help
by referring the situation in syria to
the international criminal court
despite 14 years of this council's
condemnation of the use of sexual
violence in conflict impunity prevails
not only in syria but in many other
conflicts on this council's agenda
this is often not because sexual
violence has been inadequately
criminalized or because perpetrators are
unknown
but due to a lack of political courage
the security council must call on the
syrian government
to respect international law
end attacks on civilians and civilian
infrastructure and ensure an immediate
permanent nationwide ceasefire
immediately and torture inhumane
treatment and sexual violence including
in places of arrest and detention
release all arbitrarily detained persons
allow unconditional access to all places
of detention by international
humanitarian organizations
release the names statues and locations
of all detainees and a timetable of
their release
to you the security council member
states
and the un i urge you to
refer the situation in syria to the
international criminal court
adopt a resolution on the situation of
detainees and missing persons that
underlines the syrian government's
obligations under international law and
reflects the priorities outlined by
associations representing victims
survivors and their families such as the
truth and justice charter
including support for creation of a
mechanism to clarify the fate of missing
persons and supporting their families
investigate and prosecute all
perpetrators of sexual violence and
ensure women rights are at the core of
all accountability efforts
ensure women's full equal and meaningful
participation in all ongoing and future
political peace or reconciliation
processes
prioritize a survivor-centered and
right-based approach to prevention and
mitigation of gender-based violence
ensure that the special envoy for syria
prioritizes human rights and
internationally humanitarian law
including arbitrary detention enforced
disappearance torture
and gender-based violence in political
discussions
that he convenes syrian civil society on
how to address these issues
and regularly briefs the security
councils on these efforts
renew the cross-border mechanism for at
least 12 months and reauthorize access
via all original crossing points
cross-border access is an indispensable
lifeline for millions of people in syria
the majority of whom are women and
children
pressure arms exporting countries to
stop arms proliferation and prevent the
use of weapons against all civilians
when people in syria watch conflicts
rage in ukraine and other parts of the
world today
we are reminded of our own suffering
and the abject failure of this body to
stop the violence
i joined my voice
with those of millions of girls and
women from syria who are not here with
me today and call on you to take action
there can be no peace without justice
thank you
i
thank
miss kirkutti for a very powerful
statement
um i now give the floor to miss helena
verhanu the floor is yours
mr president distinguished
representatives of member states and
honoured attendees thank you for
allowing me to bring the stories of
ethiopian women to the chamber of the
security council
i speak to you today as an egyptian
woman one who has heard these
testimonies and seen this injured
first-hand integral
one who carries the guilt of survival
and silence
today i hope to bring
i hope to do justice to the experience
of millions of different women who've
suffered in this war
in this briefing i'll focus on six
points in relation to conflict with
intersexual violence and ethiopia since
the war began integrating november 2020
and expanded to neighboring regions of
amhara and fr
these points are directly drawn from
human rights investigations and reports
that have been made public
as well as on my own visits to the
region
first rape has been perpetrated
systematically and used as a tactic of
war
it is framed as a means of represent and
leveraged as a bonding tool for members
of allied military forces
when the war first started blame a 21
year old waitress from badamere along
with a sprightly other the grand woman
was held against her weak and subjected
to sexual slavery starvation and gun
grip by a group of air transmissioners
who took turns with her
i documented many other stories like
planes during multiple visits to the
region of tigrid before june 2021
sexual violence was used to terrorize
communities as a bonding tool amongst
allied arts and defense forces ethiopian
national defense force and hara regional
militia and special forces through the
shared experiences of exploiting women's
bodies
the consistency across victims accounts
show that these crimes were committed
intentionally with a degree of
organization and planning
second sexual violence is ethnically
motivated
the grand woman was fleeing the
conflicts one with her children
along the way she encountered the tamara
militia from her family gang raped her
and inserted a hot metal rod into her
interest they declared that the grind
should never give birth
similar incidents of rape with claims of
cleansing into grand blood and leaving
women's bodies to prevent the birth of
more generations of the grounds have
been extensively covered by different
human rights reports
and third sexual violence is used to
humiliate survivors and their
communities
sexual violence has often been
preparated in front of family members an
emperor woman was beaten and raped in
the presence of her husband and a child
by two to grandma first members she and
her children with her husband being
killed as she tried to stop the
substance
men and boys were also sexually
assaulted the the human rights
commission found in sembra town of tigre
600 men and boys were stripped and
forcibly paraded some completely naked
while ultra and female soldiers mocked
them and took pictures
and fourth
women with disabilities and other
vulnerable communities have been at
particular risk during this conflict
many women with disabilities were
specifically targeted in the region of
the cry as they were presumed to be
fighters of the previous war
girls elderly women and women belonging
to minority and indigenous communities
also face higher risks
the lack of access to the region for
independent human rights monitoring has
made it difficult to document the impact
of the conflict in minority communities
and especially those living in
distributed areas on the northern on the
italian border such as europe and konami
and
and fifth the conflict in northern
ethiopia and the effective siege of
category region in particular has
undermined women's rights
including access to reproactive health
care and psychosocial supports
exacerbating the impacts of sexual
violence
in may 2021 i visited a shelter
supported by the kali university integra
where many lactating mothers and their
infants had taken refuge these women
some of whom had survived sexual assault
while being pregnant could not access
timely sexual and reproductive care owed
mainly to wide spread destruction of
medical facilities and limited
deliveries of eight due to the
government blockade of the region
the conflict in northern ethiopia has
increased
women's vulnerabilities irrespective of
their ethnicity i carry with me the
story of khadijah a nine-month pregnant
woman from afar who fled the shelling of
the ballet town by two grand opening
sources with her five children and
elderly mother
she gave birth under a tree
after working for nine days to average
while in labor
and a country with one of the highest
mathematical vitality rates globally and
lack of infrastructure specifically in
pastoral communities and areas the
conflict immediately puts the lives of
many people and women in grave danger
lack of access to psychosocial support
services also means that the mental
health of survivors hangs in the balance
many have already died by suicide the
story of a 50 year old amhara woman from
showa robert in central olympia was gun
gripped by the grand fighters in the
presence of her son in the next room and
later died of suicide
highlights how tragic the situation is
initial reports also indicates
disproportionate rates of suicide
amongst internally displaced persons
across different parts of the grind
and amid a total internet and telecom
blackout i fear at the extent of this
drama felt by the community remains
unknown
and six
wild cases of sexual violence from
tigray afar and amhara have attracted
international attention women from other
communities across ethiopia specifically
from that of the oromo kumus console
amant and somali a slickly ogarin
continue to experience conflict-related
sexual violence including by state
forces without any attention from the
international community
mr president members of the council the
central theme of today's open debate is
accountability for sexual violence
security council resolution 2467 records
the critical role of national
investigations
the dependent human rights commission
and un office for human rights were able
to conduct the joint investigation which
was limited in scope analysis but
unfortunately and more broadly we have
witnessed deliberate release of
investigation withholding of information
failings of the justice system and
destruction of evidence including
statistical records
and harassment and the teaching of
journalists by independent states and
allied parties to the conflict
as we've seen in other contexts and in
the spilling of the soir into the
broader northern region lack of
accountability and justice for past
crimes continue to fuel the sense of
grievances that drives the vicious cycle
of retaliatory attacks
based on the trains and the stories that
i i just highlighted i would like to
offer the following recommendations to
the members of the security council
first
use your platform to demand that efforts
document investigate and prevent sexual
violence and conflicts are survivor
centered and conducted in a dignified
safe and confidential manner
as part of the pursuit of justice for
survivors the security council should
also champion the work of the recently
established international commission of
human rights experts on it
including by urging all parties of the
conflict to fully cooperate and provide
unimpeded access to the commission
and second the council should demand
that all parties ensure full and safe
humanitarian access to cigarette and
other areas of conflict
and ensure that humanitarian aid
prioritizes the needs of survivors
this includes comprehensive sexual and
reproactive health care and addressing
stigma
service providers must also continue to
adhere to core humanitarian standards
including interagency standing committee
guidelines on gender-based violence and
mental health and psychosocial support
and finally
i call on the a3 the three african
countries in the security council who
can be counted as some of the strongest
voices of women peace and security in
this chamber i urge them to work here
and in the african union through its
peace and security council which has the
mandate to request a proactive
intervention from the au special envoy
on women peace and security and to take
a harder look at the prevailing view
that supporting investigations of
conflict-related sexual violence in
ethiopia could somehow derail the
proposed reform agenda of the current
government
excellencies
this war has been so devastating to
witness
first because of the sheer scale of
human suffering and second because many
defenses defended this violence in the
name of patriotism but my patriotism my
political loyalty and my allegiance lie
exclusively and partly with deep and
women and i thank you for inviting one
of those with you today
i thank miss berlin again for very
powerful
testimony and statement
i shall now make a statement in my
capacity as the representative of the
united kingdom
may i begin by thanking you special
representative premier patton
and the relationship and the strength of
the relationship between the united
kingdom and your office is something we
hold very dear and we welcome the
continued coordination and strength of
the work we're doing on this important
agenda
to our brave
activists
mariana kirkukle
and helena verhanu
for your stark insights
and also for your practical
recommendations of the responsibilities
and also the importance of action from
us the united nations security council
and of course
to you nadia murad
your determination your courage your
example
has at its heart
a real willpower to build a world for
survivors
simply put it's an inspiration for me
and i know i speak for every member of
the security council and your testimony
today
is again reflective of that central
objective that we all share
yet today as we've heard again from the
very powerful
testimonies and the report
of srsg pattern
we continue to see
disturbing reports
disturbing reports emerging yet again of
rape and sexual violence from ukraine
and we are now once again reminded that
when conflict erupts
sexual violence
soon follows as we've heard
in northern ethiopia
syria and ukraine
we have witnessed the devastating
effects on communities on families
and especially on women and girls
it is important we come together and
stand for these courageous survivors
not just to provide hope
but to provide action and ultimately
justice
it is clear that impunity continues to
be the norm
for perpetrators
it should be an exception
and we must strive for that
and frankly put
the fact here we are that this is
happening
and let us reflect on that in the year
2022
is not just unacceptable
it is utterly
shocking
and therefore we must strive we must
strive to do more collectively to end
the violence
and ultimately as we heard
from each of the very powerful
statements
deliver justice and accountability for
survivors
we need to ensure that survivors can
safely
safely record their experiences in a way
that strengthens the pursuit of justice
that is an important first yet pivotal
and crucial step towards accountability
however as we've heard from nadia
murad's powerful testimony
this is far from a reality for many
survivors around the world
and frankly put
we must ask the question of ourselves
why
why have we failed to protect why have
we failed in our collective duty to put
survivors
first
despite numerous guidance for those
collecting information and evidence from
survivors and witnesses
mistakes frankly continue to be made
mistakes not through any bad intent
yet mistakes which can
allow the wheels of justice to slow
and indeed destroy lives
too many survivors are not told about
what their options are or given the time
and space to make their own choices
about how their testimonies are best
used
too many survivors
continue to face unnecessary
re-interviewing
27 times
reflect on that figure colleagues 27
times as one courageous survivor
told me they had to give an interview
interviews are being interrupted they're
being overheard
and by that the impact of those
testimonies is diluted
and they do not meet
the threshold which too often
is put forward as the reason
why prosecutions cannot take place
the consequences
can be devastating soul destroying
ending all hope
simply put it is unacceptable
survivors are being re-traumatized time
and time again
and work
to deliver justice and accountability is
being undermined
so therefore it is vital that we end
these harmful practices
and put survivors rights at the very
heart of the evidence gathering
and therefore i'm greatly humbled as we
heard from nadiya maraad to join nadia's
initiative
and the institute for the international
criminal investigations in releasing
the murad code today
firstly i turn to you nadia
thank you
you and i have known each other many
years
you inspire me and your courage is a
powerful example
to us all as we've heard again today
and the murad code
the code to which you have
so kindly lent your name is a code of
conduct it is a code of conduct for the
collection of information and evidence
from survivors of conflict-related
sexual violence
importantly as we've heard from all the
contributions as we've heard from srsg
patton it has been shaped by survivors
survivors must be at the heart of the
solutions we seek
but also it's importantly brought
together government international
organizations and civil society
because it is our collective
responsibility to place survivors needs
at the very heart of our work
therefore i urge everyone everyone
involved in documenting and
investigating conflict-related sexual
violence
follow the morad code
in fact go further i would say
to my mind it should become the very
gold standard for any ngo for any
government any government agency human
rights institution civil society group
working in the field
putting survivors first and at the
center of investigations
should not be an option
it should be done by everyone everywhere
but our collective efforts cannot stop
there
this year we are exploring all options
to strengthen international action
including an international convention as
proposed by our foreign secretary liz
truss
and today i'm also pleased to announce
that from the 28th to the 30th of
november
we will also host an international
conference on this very issue
on preventing
on preventing sexual violence in
conflict marking 10 years since we
launched that very initiative
we will also importantly continue to
bring faith and belief leaders together
in support of survivors through the
declaration of humanity it cannot be
right
groups such as daish and others
who use the veil of religion erroneously
and perversely to somehow justifies
their abhorrent crimes and actions faith
leaders
are and continue to stand up to say very
clearly not in the name of our religion
and not in the name of any faith or
belief across the world
we will also make further progress to
enhance the rights and well-being of
children born of sexual violence and
rape
i was honored to announce a call to
action last november but let's put that
into perspective
a child born of such a crime
they should be given compassion
instead they are stigmatized they are
given rejection that has to change at
all levels
and we will also respond more robustly
to reports of sexual violence in
conflict wherever whenever they occur
we've just heard from helena just now
about the distressing situation in
ethiopia
the nature and scale of reports of
sexual violence that have come out of
tigre
amhara and afar
are deeply deeply disturbing
yet many communities as we've heard from
that very testimony remain cut off from
communications and therefore unable to
tell their story
seek the hope and indeed the support
they need
and that is why it was important to us
today the united kingdom and i thank our
ambassador and her team in this regard
to invite the first ethiopian civil
society representative to brief this
security council on the situation in
northern ethiopia
and what's more to hear directly from
you felina an ethiopian woman who has
been integral to feminist youth
movements and who has recently worked
with communities across the country who
have been affected by conflict related
sexual violence
the united kingdom government has
committed more than seven million pounds
to support survivors in northern
ethiopia and improve national
accountability systems and we will also
continue to work to provide expertise to
build capacity to hold perpetrators to
account
and i welcome in this respect the
gauntlet was thrown down but for my
colleagues from the african union i pay
tribute to the african union's
leadership on conflict-related sexual
violence 30 african countries now have a
national action plan on women peace and
security providing the very essential
framework for addressing this issue and
women's political participation in
conflict affected context
it's essential mariana again made that
point we have within the un framework
srsg pattern and i discuss this
we have within the un family
incredible mediation networks of women
we need to ensure that expertise those
insights are deployed directly not just
in resolving conflicts but in actually
building sustainable peace
sadly again we've heard from mariana of
how rape is being used and continues to
be used to destroy the lives of many
syrian women and girls by various
parties to the conflict
and the united kingdom continues
to support and provide support in that
area four million pounds through its
conflict stability and security fund has
been used in response to that crisis
we've also strengthened the medical
documentation of attacks in accordance
with international standards and
improved support services for survivors
and i am absolutely convinced that the
marathon will be an important
contribution to enhance that collection
of evidence i was also pleased to see
the first conviction for
conflict-related sexual violence in
syria
delivered in koblenz in january
let me assure you as we look around the
world the united kingdom will also
continue to support afghan women
who face some of the highest rates of
violence in the world and are watching
the progress made
in recent decades unravel in front of
their eyes
and let us also send a very clear
message
to those who seek to suppress women's
rights who seek to suppress the rights
of education for girls and yes that is a
message clearly for the taliban to hear
islam as a religion
based itself on equality for girls and
rights for women
islam is clear are you
empower girls educate girls empower
women the evidence is in front of you
societies prospers
prosper nations progress
we are also pushing to integrate
services for all survivors of
gender-based violence including sexual
violence into afghan healthcare
provision
and that's been informed directly
by the people who know best
many leaders afghan women leaders who
are helping us on this important agenda
we are also working with the
international rescue committee the un
population fund and others on programs
to protect women and girls and provide
access to gender-based violence services
colleagues members of the security
council
we are collectively shocked
at the abhorrent testimonies we hear in
every conflict
but today as we sit here the abhorrent
testimonies which are emerging from
ukraine
the reports of rape and sexual violence
committed by russian armed forces must
be properly investigated
and that is why the united kingdom
has worked with partners to refer the
situation in ukraine to the
international criminal court to
establish a commission of inquiry
through the un human rights council and
with the support directly of ukraine to
establish an osce mission of experts
in march we announced an additional 1
million pounds in funding for the icc to
help uncover evidence of war crimes
and let me put it simply
and starkly
sexual violence
rape
it's a vile vile stain on humanity
wherever it occurs whoever the
perpetrators it is our collective moral
duty
indeed it is our absolute obligation to
work together to help survivors and do
all we can to stamp it out
and as nadia said
we must work together to provide the
routes and avenues to see justice for
survivors
to perpetrators we must send a very
clear message
a clear message not just from the
security council but every person in
every society must be determined to send
that same unequivocal message in all its
clarity
you will be found
you will face just it
justice you will be held to account
and finally to the survivors
to those who are here and the courageous
survivors around the world
thank you
thank you for the hope that you provide
in the face
of such challenge in the face
of
unimaginable consequences you have faced
thank you for your courage and
conviction to carry on
sexual violence
is not just a crime against you
it's a crime against our common and
shared humanity
we stand for you
and we will always stand with you
thank you
i now resume my function as president of
the council
and i give the floor to her excellency
miss linda thomas greenfield
permanent representative of the united
states and member of president biden's
cabinet
your excellency
thank you mr president and thank you so
much for convening this very important
uh discussion today
i also want to thank special
representative patton for your remarks
the united states is proud to support
the important work of the srsg's office
and most of all
thank you to the three briefers
thank you for sharing your powerful
stories your courage
and your strength
as an inspiration to all of
us as we all know sexual violence is a
horrific and deliberate tactic and
conflict
it is used to terrorize to destabilize
to break communities and people down
its impact ripple out far beyond
survivors and it fuels instability
unfortunately this unspeakable practice
is not new
i was recalling as you all spoke in the
early 90s
attending meetings with somali women who
were victims of violence in somalia
and hearing their horrific stories of
rape
and their plea to all of us to support
them
and here we are today
hearing those same pleas from all of you
the same acts of violence are still
being
committed around the world
today
and women like those somali women that i
spoke to in the 1990s are sitting
here listening at us today
on monday we outline the threats to
women and girls in ukraine from russia's
brutal and unprovoked war
and we cannot forget
a look away from the way rape and sexual
violence have been used as a weapon of
war in ethiopia and syria and other
conflicts around the world
this council has spent a great deal of
time discussing these issues
noting
them with great concern
well now it's time for us to act
as we heard today expressions of concern
are not enough
first
we and all governments need to hold
perpetrators accountable
we must do more as a global community to
actually implement the international
commitments we've all agreed to as ms
patton said to us uh today
governments
instead of denying these acts
must acknowledge them and they must
address them
they have to stop
intimidating victims
silencing their voices
solacing those who raise concern and
advocate for them
and hold those responsible accountable
we must
explore ways to use the diplomatic tools
we have as both individual member states
and as a collective
to do everything we can to ensure
perpetrators do not get away with these
acts of conflict-related sexual violence
and that means strengthening
quality ethical and effective
documentation efforts
we caution against any action that would
duplicate or dilute the efficacy of our
existing security council mandates and
legal frameworks
we have the tools we need
we just need to use them
we cannot let ourselves get distracted
from the urgency of accountability
especially in those settings where we
continue to receive reports of
conflict-related sexual violence
after all holding perpetrators
accountable is not only the right thing
to do
it deters others from enacting this
violence in the future
it strengthens the rule of law
it makes reconciliation more likely and
it makes inclusive and democratic
transition
possible
second we must defend and empower
survivors through a survivor-centered
approach
that means listening to survivors
responding to their unique needs and
providing the resources and legal
support
they ask for and that they need
we have learned just how important it is
to create a supportive environment to
avoid re-traumatizing those who have
experienced conflict-related sexual
violence and to ensure that they are
treated with dignity and respect
when we provide survivors with the
resources they need to heal
and to recover
we help them
tremendously and we help break the
silence and the stigma surrounding
sexual violence and conflict as well
centering our support around survivors
while securing justice for them
is the clearest and the most powerful
way to empower survivors to become
agents of peace and voices of change as
we see from our colleague nadia across
this room and again nadia thank you so
much for bringing your voice to us today
third and finally
because all gender-based violence is
rooted in gender inequality we must
advance the empowerment of women and
girls in all of their diversity
to that in the united nations and all
member states should apply conflict
sensitive and participatory gender
analysis to our interventions and to our
work
we need to ensure we are addressing the
underlying societal norms and power
relations that when combined with weak
or absent state institutions lead to
gender-based violence
we need to advance gender sensitive
early warning and response and we must
persevere in our promotion of the
meaningful participation of women in
decision-making roles especially in
conflict prevention resolution and
peacekeeping processes
when we integrate women and girls into
atrocity prevention efforts we we do
more to prevent those atrocities
it is that simple
in the long term the best defense
against conflict-related sexual violence
is an equal and just society one where
all women and girls have respect for
their human rights
and where we enjoy equal protection
under the law where we have timely
access to justice and where we have the
educational opportunities we all deserve
as the late secretary albright used to
say
democracy is apparent to peace
and common sense tells us that true
democracy is not possible without the
full participation of women
so let us make democracy possible
let us build those just and inclusive
societies
and in the meantime let us hold
perpetrators accountable take a survivor
approach and integrate gender equity in
everything we do
and as nadia said survivors don't want
our pity
they want justice
they all have made all of the
women who spoke today they all have made
recommendations to us today
let's pay homage to them
and follow their lead
thank you mr president
i thank
her excellency ambassador ms thomas
greenfield for her statement i now give
the floor to the representative of
norway madam ambassador
thank you president
and thanks to special representative of
the secretary general pramila patton
and to the civil society briefers for
your very valuable statements
time and time again
we here in this chamber how sexual
violence is being used as a tactical war
and every year these reports put into
stark relief
how we continue to fall short in
effectively addressing both the
immediate effects and the root causes of
conflict-related violence
a grave violation of international law
this is completely abhorrent
i therefore wish to thank the uk for
focusing this year's open debate on
accountability
as prevention
and i want to thank especially nadia
marina and helena
for your very powerful interventions and
for sharing your recommendations
your testimonies remind us how
participation
and protection are inextricably linked
we see in syria as mariana so strongly
have testified
conflict-related violence in detention
settings
the heightened risk of sexualized
violence against displaced women
and negative coping mechanisms such as
child labour and early enforced
marriages
these are a particular concern
in ethiopia we are horrified by the
numerous reports of and from what we
heard from helena systematic rape and
gender-based violence
and we welcome the commissioner expert
established by the human rights council
to investigate allegations of human
rights violations and abuses by all
parties
this is essential for occupant
accountability prevention and
reconciliation
and in ukraine we are deeply shocked by
the atrocities committed against
civilians in places that have been held
by russian forces as well as the
disturbing reports of conflict-related
sexual violence
ukrainian women and girls are played are
placed further at risk by targeted
russian attacks against civilian
infrastructure
forcing displacement and family
separation and report depriving victims
and survivors from access to essential
health services
president in this council we are still
discussing what a comprehensive human
rights-based and survivor center
approach means
to make the move to actual
implementation we must recognize the
root causes of crsv and dare to suggest
concrete measures
in this period
i will put forward three areas that
norway firmly believes will promote
accountability
and prevention
if
sufficiently scaled up
addressed jointly and through
multi-stakeholder coordination
first we must build the capacity of law
enforcement
security and military sector personnel
in both u.n peace operation and national
institutions
this helps reinforce accountability
structures
tackles underlying structural
inequalities and attitudes and ensures
that policies and action plans are
actually
put to use
a good example is how the unmiss sgbv
specialized police team is supporting
south sudan's national police service
second we must invest in accept in
access to coordinated health care and
services legal services and information
a commendable example is unfpa's
one-stop center which are established in
cooperation with local authorities like
in mosul
iraq third placing the need of survivors
at the center of our effort means also
promoting and supporting their agencies
they themselves must be allowed to
define and design what they think are
necessary measures for
prevention protection and accountability
as usg patent has highlighted
reparations are what survivors of srsv
request most and yet still receive la
least
let me also congratulate you nadya and
the uk
on tomorrow's launch of the morad code
an important initiative to place
survivors right at the center of the
investigations and documentation of crsv
president financing and resources go
hand in hand with monitoring and
implementation of all three of these
recommendations
as
has been highlighted by the usgs office
and echoed by you and women unfbi and
civil society the scale of the resources
is far from equal to the scale of
actions needed on the ground
council members and the broader u.n
membership must join forces to ensure
that the un and csos have the necessary
expertise financing and access in place
president a final point we all recognize
that the elephant in the room is the
lack of political will
by sending a strong collective signal
through all councils decisions
and in our dialogue with conflict
parties we must remind them of their
obligation and influence their actions
and we must insist on women's full equal
and meaningful participation
and protection from violence not merely
as
an end in itself but as a prerequisite
for peace and stability
i hope this council will send a strong
signal today
clearly condemning any and all use of
conflict-related sexual violence thank
you
i thank the representative of norway
thank you madam ambassador i now give
the floor to the representative of the
united arab emirates your excellency mr
president lord ahmed i would like uh to
begin by thanking you and welcoming you
for sharing this important open debate
we are delighted that the uk has joined
the shared women peace and security
presidency commitment and we welcome the
growing number of uh signatories i would
like also to thank special president
patton for her detailed briefing and the
critical work of her of her office
i also want to thank miss morad for her
insightful briefing
um the uae has always admired miss
brad's courageous work and we are proud
to support nadia's initiative her
non-profit empowering the brave yazidi
women of iraq
i listened also carefully to the
briefings by mrs karkoutly and miss
verhano
mr president
sexual and gender-based violence is a
despicable scourge and this council must
do more to prevent it in conflict
situations
when such violence is used as a tool of
war it exacerbates conflict and sets
back progress towards inclusive equal
and stable societies
as the rate of conflict and instability
around the world increases
so too have the disturbing reports on
the situation of women and girls in
these settings
women and girls in afghanistan continue
to be subjected to sexual slavery and
rape
in syria and iraq the heinous acts of
daesh continue to have an impact
at the ukrainian border women and girls
are targeted by human and sex
traffickers
as they flee the conflict
and as we also heard today the tragic
experiences of women and girls face in
many other conflicts
the united ms therefore welcome welcomes
the focus on the structural prevention
resilience building and accountability
in the secretary general's report this
year
as members of the international
community the security council and the
wider u.n membership have a
responsibility to prioritize prevention
ensure accountability and end this
horror
in this regard we would like to make the
following recommendations
first the most effective response to
sexual and gender-based violence is
preventing it from happening in the
first place
as this special representative has
pointed out time and again effective
prevention strategies require addressing
root causes most notably structural
gender inequality and harmful social
norms
this includes strengthening women's and
goals resilience by ensuring they enjoy
equal access to public life education
and economic participation
recognizing and understanding their role
as active agents of change and dynamic
members of society is thus the first
step in prevention
second accountability needs to be
pursued by upholding and strengthening
the rule of law
there is a transformative period
following conflict and crisis to
strengthen the capacity of relevant
nationalist institutions such as law
enforcement and the security sector so
that they may better uphold the rule of
law
capacity building if coupled with the
deployment of gender and protection
expertise that focuses on a
survivor-centered approach can be a
critical tool to establish a system that
promotes accountability
third the international community must
hold non-state armed groups accountable
for conflict-related sexual violence not
least because they are an increasingly
central actors in conflict settings
grave violations of international
humanitarian law and human rights law
require accountability
a strong tool for the security council
to achieve this is to include
conflict-related sexual violence as a
stand-alone designation criterion for
sanctions and to list individuals and
entities whenever they are responsible
for the commission of such acts
in this regard we welcome the recent
decision made by the council to
designate the houthis as an entity
including for perpetrating a policy of
sexual violence in conflict
efforts like these contribute to the
prevention of and response to these
crimes on the ground and council members
must remain consistent in their approach
in conclusion there is no justification
for the fact that conflict-related
sexual violence remains a reality
the council the un its member states the
private sector and cyber civil society
must work together and make it a
priority to eliminate these crimes once
and for all i thank you mr president
i thank the representative of the united
um
arab emirates i now give the floor to
the representative of india mr
ambassador flores
thank you mr president
at the outset we thank the united
kingdom for convening the open debate on
this important issue
we also thank srsg pramila patton
and all other distinguished briefers for
sharing their insights
in the last three decades the
international community has played an
important role in fixing accountability
for conflict-related sexual violence
thereby sending out a strong message
that sexual violence has no place in the
civilized world
the prosecutions of conflict-related
sexual crimes by the international
criminal tribunal for the former
yugoslavia and for rwanda
u.n security council resolutions on
sexual violence
and united kingdoms preventing sexual
violence and conflict initiative have
contributed to addressing this complex
and sensitive issue in its entirety
despite this progress it is indeed
distressing that sexual violence and
conflict situations continue unabated
amidst a culture of immune impunity
as a tactic of war torture and terror in
armed conflicts especially by non-state
actors
again
despite the robust framework put in
place by the security council since 2007
with the launching of the u.n action
against sexual violence and conflict the
levels of compliance by parties to the
conflict remains
low
majority of the parties listed in the
secretary general's annual report on
conflict-related sexual violence are
persistent perpetrators who continue to
commit or abet
sexual violence in armed situations
this must stop
the council must focus on identifying
and bridging the implementation gaps to
prevent the atrocities and facilitate
the rehabilitation and reintegration of
survivors
mr president my delegation wishes to
highlight the following six issues for
the consideration of the council
first national governments have the
primary responsibility for prosecuting
and deterring such crimes in conflict
situations on their territories even if
these are alleged to have been committed
by non-state actors
member states should ensure effective
prosecution of sexual violence as a
self-standing crime
second upon request the u.n must assist
national authorities in developing
capabilities to strengthen their
national legal frameworks and related
structures
for speedy investigation and prosecution
of perpetrators
this should also be a priority in
postcolonic situations to address
holistically the structural and
cross-cutting gender inequalities that
perpetuate sexual violence
third the member states must adopt a
victim-centered approach to preventing
and responding to sexual violence in
armed conflicts in line with resolution
2467 that seeks to strengthen justice
and accountability and calls for a
survivor-centered approach in the
prevention and response to
conflict-related sexual violence
states must ensure adequate focus and
resources for comprehensive and
non-discriminatory assistance for
victims of sexual violence by providing
for medical psychological social and
legal services
a key starting point in strengthening
the accountability process is by
addressing the endemic stigma attached
to survivors of sexual violence and fear
of reprisals by offenders thereby
helping them to come forward to speak to
investigators and testify in court
fourth
terrorism and violent extremism
conducive to terrorism continue to be
the biggest global threat to peace and
security with women suffering
disproportionately in the resulting
conflicts engendered by them
sexual violence primarily directed
against women and girls and increasingly
among men and boys by terrorists remains
a course of concern
the nexus between terrorism trafficking
and sexual violence in arms armed
conflict needs to be broken
fifth
the sanctions regimes and other targeted
measures by the council
need to be strengthened to utilize their
full potential to deter perpetrators of
sexual violence in armed conflict
last but not the least the member states
must provide a conducive environment for
the participation and inclusion of women
in political processes and decision
making
india has moved ahead from women's
development to women-led development
we have been advocating this idea for
lasting peace in our neighborhood
including in afghanistan in line with
the u.n security council resolution 2593
especially relating to women children
and minorities
mr president in 2017 prime minister modi
joined the circle of leadership that was
formally established by the secretary
general at the high level meeting on the
prevention of sexual exploitation and
abuse in the united nations operations
india has also signed the secretary
general's voluntary compact against
sexual exploitation and abuse
india has the distinction of sending the
first all-women formed police unit
contingent to liberia in 2007.
this unit mitigated incidents of crime
against women deterred sexual and
gender-based violence and helped rebuild
safety and confidence among the liberian
population
in this process it also operationalized
the spirit of the landmark security
council
three
resolution
five on women peace and security into
action
these courageous indian women patrol
monrovian streets at night taught
liberian women
self defense skills and conducted
classes on combating
the number of women peacekeepers we also
support increasing the deployment of
women protection advisors for effective
monitoring analysis and reporting
arrange agreements arrangements on
conflict-related sexual violence in the
field
to conclude india reaffirms its
commitment to actively contribute
to a collective endeavor in effectively
tackling sexual violence in situations
of armed conflict i thank you mr
president
i thank uh the representative of india
thank you
mr ambassador we i now give the floor to
the representative of brazil your
excellency
many thanks mr president
it is highly regrettable to be here
today calling once more for an end to an
utterly unacceptable crime committed
most against women and women and girls
but also against men and boys
sexual violence in conflict destroys the
social fabric of communities
it inflicts long-lasting psychological
trauma having a direct bearing on the
resilience of people of peace and on the
prospects for sustainable development
perpetrators be they state or non-state
actors terrorists or mercenaries should
now be thinking twice before they commit
such crimes but they do not stop they
continue because they know that most
probably their actions will go
unpunished even though they are
committing well-known violations of
international human rights
and international humanitarian law
abhorrent acts prohibited both in times
of war and peace
today's briefings and the latest report
of the secretary general serve as stark
reminders that the fight to end sexual
violence as a weapon of war
as a tool of intimidation and social
control in conflict and post-conflict
situations is very far from over
mr president lord ahmad
brazil thanks to united kingdom for
organizing today's debate and the
briefers for their comprehensive
presentations
in addition to that we take this
opportunity to command special
representative pramila pramila patton
for her work and and her office
for the crucial role they play in
international efforts to combat sexual
violence and conflict
we also thank miss nadia murad
mariana
karkoutly and
helena bergano for their testimonials
they show us the strength of the
committed work of victims themselves and
of their organizations on the ground
addressing the prevailing culture of
impunity for the crime of sexual
violence and conflict is paramount
not just as a means of reparation but
also of delivering justice by making
perpetrators accountable for their
crimes
it is also
as experienced shows
an important tool to prevent the
horrific scenarios described by the
aforementioned reports in a myriad of
other accounts
as ms simmers bauhaus told us on monday
and mrs pramila confirmed today
red signs are now flying all over as
allegations of sexual violence are
reported in the context of the conflict
in ukraine
brazil reiterates its calls for urgent
independent investigations of such
allegations and welcomes the
participation of u.n women experts
skilled and experienced to investigate
sexual violence abuse and exploitation
in the works of the commission of
inquiry of the human rights council
this council should should respond
appropriately to all allegations of
sexual violence in conflicts under its
agenda
this response must recognize the problem
and strengthen whenever appropriate the
mandates of peacekeeping operations and
special political missions as to promote
real changes on the ground
recent reports from south sudan offer a
horrific account of sexual violence
being used as a weapon of war
in reminders of the grave consequences
of widespread impunity for sexual
violence and conflict
the recent approved resolution 2625 in
south sudan which renews the mandate of
unmiss
expresses serious concerns at those
ongoing reports and underlines the
urgency
of timely investigations not only to
support accountability
but also to provide assistance and
protection to survivors
it enables unmiss to curb sexual
violence within its core directive for
the protection of civilians in fact
unmiss may use a variety of means and
areas of deployment to deter
prevent and respond to sexual and
gender-based violence including by
facilitating access to organizations
that provide services and support to
survivors
but having such provisions in the
council's resolutions is not enough
this council must urgently address the
funding shortfalls that prevent it from
delivering a satisfactory response
and that includes having the resources
for instance
to continue to deploy women's protection
advisors to bring behavioral change
through engagement with the parties to
the conflict
it is also essential to guarantee that
pre-deployment training of u.n troops
and personnel includes capacity building
to recognize and respond
to sexual violence and conflict
including on early warning and risk
mitigation
troops should be trained to help foster
an enabling an enabling via environment
for surviving victims to seek support
and for perpetrators to be persecuted
for their crimes
peace agreements and post-conflict
arrangements hardly ever deal with the
situation of those who have been
subjected to violence during conflict in
india's aftermath
by the support of the peace building
commission this council should continue
to advocate for the inclusion of
references in peace agreements consider
the imperative to ideally at least
eradicate all forms of sexual violence
especially against all women and girls
and of provisions related to
accountability for gender-based violence
promoting full equal and meaningful
participation of women in
decision-making processes
and p in peace talks also means tackling
the root causes of sexual violence and
conflict
including structural gender inequality
and harmful social norms that lead to
the stigmatization and discrimination of
survivors
any and every step towards the
implementation of women and peace and
security resolutions is very much
welcome
thank you mr president
i thank the representative of brazil
i now give the floor to the
representative of china
mr president
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
uh
uh
ugh
good afternoon uh we're delighted to be
joined by the secretary general by the
deputy secretary general and by rebecca
greenspan the secretary general of
unctad we are here
to launch the report global impact of
war in ukraine on food energy and
finance systems uh the secretary general
will make some opening remarks uh miss
greenspan uh will also make uh short
remarks on the report and then we'll
open it up to questions sir please
well ladies and gentlemen of the press
thank you very much for coming
now since the russian federation's
invasion of ukraine the world's
attention has been focused on the wars
terrifying levels of deaths destruction
and suffering
and from the start the united nations
has been actively engaged in delivering
humanitarian support to the people in
ukraine the people that is paying are
paying their highest price
and to the host countries of the fastest
growing refugee crisis in europe since
the second world war
but less attention has been paid to the
global impact of the war in all its
dimensions
in a world that was already witnessing
increased poverty hunger and social
unrest
the war is supercharging a
three-dimensional
food energy and finance
that is pummeling some of the world's
most vulnerable people countries and
economies
and all this comes at a time when
developing countries are already
struggling
with the slate of challenges not of
their making
the covet 19 pandemic
climate change
and the lack of access to adequate
resources to finance the recovery in the
context of persistent and growing
inequalities
we are now facing a perfect storm
that threatens to devastate the
economies of many developing countries
and that is why in the earliest days of
this war i established the global crisis
response group on food energy and
finance
facilitated by a task team in the u.n
secretariat
reporting to a steering committee
involving all u.n agencies and
international financial institutions
today we are launching the task team's
first report
and i'm joined by the secretary general
of unkthat rebecca greenspan who
coordinates the task team
and by the deputy secretary general who
presides over the steering committee
ms greenspan will go through the
recommendations
but i want to highlight two overarching
points made crystal clear in this report
first the impact of the war is global
and systemic
as many as 1.7 billion people
one set of women are already living in
poverty
are now highly exposed to disruptions in
food
energy and finance systems
that are triggering increases in poverty
and hunger
36 countries count on russia and ukraine
for more than half of their within ports
including some of the poorest and most
vulnerable countries of the world
and prices were already on the rise but
the war has made a bad situation far
worse
wheat and maize prices have been very
volatile since the war began but are
still 30 percent higher just since the
start of the year
at the same time russia is a top energy
supplier
oil prices are up more than 60 percent
over the past year accelerating the
prevailing trends
the same goes for natural gas prices
which have risen by 50
in recent months
and fertilizer prices have more than
double
as prices climb
so does hunger and malnutrition
especially for young children
inflation is rising purchasing power is
eroding
gross prospects are shrinking
and development is being stalled in some
cases gains are receding
many developing economies are drowning
in debt
with bond deals already on the rise
since last september leaving now to
increase risk premiums and exchange rate
pressures
and this is setting in motion a
potential vicious circle of inflation
and stagnation the so called stagflation
the report also shows that there is a
direct correlation between rising food
prices and social and political
instability
our world cannot afford these
we need to act now
and that leads to the second point
clearly demonstrated by this response
we can do something about this
three-dimensional crises
we have the capacity to cushion the blow
and the reports offers more than a dozen
recommendations but i would boil down
the messages to three fundamental points
first we must not make things worse
that means ensuring a steady flow of
food and energy through open markets it
means lifting all unnecessary export
restrictions and this is not the time
for protectionism
and it means directing surpluses and
reserves to those in need
and keeping a lead on food prices and
calming the volatility in food markets
second we can maximize this moment to
push for the transformational change our
world needs
look no further than the energy crisis
in the immediate term
countries must resist hoarding and
release strategic stockpiles and
additional reserves
but now is also the time to turn this
crisis into an opportunity we must work
towards progressively phasing out coal
and other fossil fuels and accelerating
the deployment of renewable energy and
the just transition
and third we need to pull developing
countries back from the financial brink
the international financial system has
deep pockets
i've been strongly advocating for its
reform
but developing countries need help now
and the funds are there
so we need to make them available to
economies that need them most
so that governments can avoid default
provides social safety nets for the
poorest and most vulnerable
and continue to make critical
investments in sustainable development
this is not a crisis that can be solved
piecemeal country by country
this global and systemic emergency
requires global and systemic solutions
and the report includes concrete
recommendations for international
financial institutions to increase
liquidity and fiscal space
as we approach the spring meetings of
the world bank and the imf
we need political will and leadership
resources are available
we must speak with one voice
action today will prevent suffering
tomorrow
dear friends above all
this war must end
the people of ukraine cannot bear the
violence being inflicted on them and the
most vulnerable people around the world
cannot become collateral damage in yet
another disaster for which they bear no
responsibility
we need to silence the guns and
accelerate negotiations towards peace
now
for the people of ukraine for the people
of the region and for the people
of the world
thank you
rebecca
thank you very much secretary general
for for your words and most importantly
for for raising your voice for the
developing countries and the people that
are suffering the consequences of this
consecutive crisis
and for establishing the global crisis
group on food energy and finance and
the
steering committee their dsg and
the testing
so
as the secretary general have said and
already established this is a
a crisis
and i want to go with you towards
through the recommendations that we are
given to
cushion the blow as the secretary
general have a rightly said
in terms of the food crisis
uh
the most important thing that the
secretary
general has already said is to keep
markets open
we urge all countries to keep their food
markets open and to seize
any restrictions that
will maintain
a
the international trade and food in food
and fertilizers not flowing to the
countries that need them
hoarding and speculative movements
threaten food supplies
and we need solidarity in these times of
crisis
so the first thing
let's keep markets open
second
let's help countries help their poor
countries will need help and support to
be able to establish the safety nets
and
be able to support the households that
will suffer from this crisis
poor households dedicate most of their
income to food
and so the increase in food crisis in
food prices
it really hurt them the most
we need
to help countries to help the poor
households and vulnerable households
that will suffer from this war and for
that they will need financial support
third
let's
help these small farmers because these
small farmers will be hit
by the prices of fertilizers
so we need to prevent
from production going down in the next
cycle
so let's try to support
livelihoods
not only lives
and livelihoods will be important for
small farmers and food producers and
local food processors to have we need
them to have adequate access to seeds to
fertilizers and to fuels
and
the last recommendation is to keep
the freight prices stable and
predictable because part of the cost
and the rising prices
in food in
energy comes from very steep increases
in the freight
cost for trade
and obviously dear secretary general as
you have always insisted
food purchases by the united nations
world food program the world's biggest
provider of humanitarian assistance must
be exempt from any food restrictions
with immediate effect so they can
continue to perform their duties
with respect to fuel
we know that gas and fertilizer prices
have more than doubled
as the secretary general already
explained
so we urge governments to continue a
coordinated approach to make strategic
reserves
available to the global market
and where possible we must reduce the
use of wheat for biofuels because we
will need wheat
for
food
we must ensure support for the
vulnerable countries and vulnerable
populations who must be able to afford
fuel but let's try to support them
by giving
to people the resources they need
to be able to have access to energy
because universal
subsidies to fossil fuels
will be very difficult to bring down
afterwards so let's help help people in
households and not you know people that
not necessarily will benefit from it
in finance
and let me go
sorry let me go for
an another very important recommendation
and is that we demand
more efficient energy consumption
that will help drive the energy
transition
you know
we demand more ethical behavior from all
of us so we can push and use this
opportunity for the energy transition
and not like the secretary general said
a a see
regress in terms of more sustainable
energy sources we can do
more
with less
we can be more have more sustainable
behavior to accelerate the transition
so now let's go to finance
as the secretary general said we are on
the brink of a global debt crisis we
already have seen that in several
countries already
yesterday we had the default of sri
lanka and other countries are already
asking for help for
their debt crisis we have to prevent
another lost decade for developing
countries
so
a we
need to enact immediately in the
international financial
system
the international monetary fund and the
world bank
to do everything possible to ensure
more liquidity to the countries
making use
of the already
windows that they have for fast
disbursement for emergency
let me say that they have done that
before they have done that in the crisis
of
the pandemic of covet 19
so we need them to do it again we need
them to put those windows
very quickly to be accessed by the
countries that
really need them
we also call on the international
monetary fund to increase and maintain
access limits for rapid financial
assistance
increase the annual access limits to the
rapid credit facility and the rapid
financing instruments to crisis levels
and extend the existing cumulative
access limit towards 2024 because many
countries already use a lot of their
quota
in the former pandemic
you said precisely secretary general
that this comes on top of climate change
and this comes on top of the
a
pandemic
the crisis that
this country suffered with the pandemic
so they have exhausted a lot of the
possibilities and the space that they
had with the international organizations
so we need to increase
the
access limit that they have so they can
have access to those resources
and we need to suspend interest rates
surcharges for at least
two years because this is a global
pandemic it doesn't make sense
to charge countries a surcharge in
interest
on a global
crisis that they didn't enact that is
not bad behavior that is not their
immediate responsibility so it doesn't
make sense to have this surcharges that
are
a
a a factor that depends the problem that
these countries are going through
and for sure we need to
operationalize very quickly the
resilience and sustainability trust that
the imf has proposed
and let me be clear on this because
these are
instruments that are already there
that they can use immediately that only
need flexibility and political will to
be a
for for them to be put into operation
very quickly so
the rst the
resilience and sustainable
sustainability trust that the imf has
proposed is a very important instrument
so we need that to be operationalized
immediately and we need to raise our
voices for the countries that have these
special drawing rights and don't don't
need them
to give them to the resilient and
sustainability trust
there are
400 billion
equivalent
dollars yes
in special drawing rights that are in
the hands of countries that don't need
it
this is a very large sum of resources so
we need the countries and we pledge the
countries to really
give
those
sdrs to the imf so the resilient and
sustainability trust can really be there
for the access of the developing
countries that will need it in this
in this present crisis
and we have to support
the
debt
a
initiative that was approved in dg20 for
the low-income countries but that has
not been extended the ssi has to be
extended for all the low income
countries immediately precisely for that
relief because that issues need to move
higher in the political agenda political
will and international leadership are
essential to do that and we need really
to avoid a domino effect in terms of
debt because
that is piling up in many of these
countries because of this
successive
crisis
and finally
if you allow me secretary general
to really claim for instruments of
climate and nature that relief there is
a clear opportunity to learn from the
past
and be able to go for a
sk and scale up a comprehensive
large-scale debt relief
linked to improve climate adam
adaptation and mitigation in the context
of food security precisely because of
the war
in ukraine
and finally a revised an implementable
g20 common framework for that
treatment is needed urgently to provide
timely debt restructuring to countries
in need
many of this
initiative are there but they have not
been able to be in the quantum that the
world
need because we didn't think that the
pandemic will last for two years and not
for one we didn't think
that there would come another crisis on
top of kobe 19 that is the war in
ukraine with these increases in prices
of food and energy so we need to scale
up the instruments that we already have
to be able to give the country to relief
to caution the blow like the secretary
general has said to really help
developing countries to go through this
crisis this is not a crisis of one or
two countries there are
107
countries that have exposure severe
exposure to at least one of the
dimensions of this crisis to the
increase in food or to the increase in
energy or to the increase in tightening
conditions in finance and this
this
says that these 107 countries can get
into an unstable
economy in an unstable
a political
a blow because of this severe exposure
to one of these three-dimensional crises
that we are suffering and from those 107
a secretary general as you said these
107 countries 69 countries
have exposure severe exposure to the
three dimensions
they are severely exposed exposed
to food increases a price increases
severe severely exposed to increases in
energy prices severely exposed to very
difficult financial conditions with no
fiscal space and with no external
financing to caution the blow on the
most vulnerable on the poor so we need
to be able to push the international
community
to act with the urgency that these
figures show today and
a accompany and a be together with the
voice of the secretary general that has
raised his voice to really
put that put the attention and awareness
on the difficult situation that other
countries are suffering precisely
because they weren't right
thank you
thank you very much rebecca we'll go to
ed letter associated press
um mr secretary general mr miss
madame deputy secretary general emmis
greenspun thank you very much for doing
this briefing on behalf of the united
nations correspondents association
welcome
mr secretary general you've talked about
the need
for political will and leadership
what actions are
the united nations taking to
generate this political will and
leadership
to address these issues quickly
and how optimistic are you that this is
going to happen
and you've
also stated quite clearly that the war
must end
yet
yesterday we heard the president of
russia saying
it isn't going to end until their goals
are met and
basically ruling out
negotiations so
what's happening with
your effort to get a humanitarian
ceasefire
well there are
several questions and i'll try to answer
all of them
first of all
we are approaching a crucial moment
for
many of the decisions we are talking
about the spring meetings of the imf and
world bank
and both the imf and world bank are part
of the steering committee we are in
close contact with them and
today
four members of our steering committee
have made an appeal in relation to food
security including the imf and world
bank and so this is a crucial moment
to make sure that member states that are
represented in the spring meetings
understand the need to use the
instruments that imf and world bank and
other international financial
institutions have the instruments are
there
as i said the pockets
are deep
and the money is there but it needs to
be used this is a crucial moment
now to make sure that we are able to um
develop political leadership
i invited
six heads of state and government
to be champions of
this process and
i can announce you that they have
accepted it will be
co-chairing with me the president of
senegal that is president of the african
union
the president of indonesia the prime
minister of germany the prime minister
of barbados the prime minister of
denmark and the prime minister of
bangladesh
and we'll be working together in making
sure that we do global advocacy in
relation to all these questions that we
mobilize political will
because
the amount of suffering we are
witnessing in ukraine of course and
let's not forget it but around the world
by people that have already uh
suffered the impact of
many uh dramatic consequences of climate
change of the covet of the lack of
vaccination of the lack of financial
resources
for
recovery now this blow is really too
much and we need really to have a sense
of urgency
resources are there measures can be
taken quickly several countries have
important stocks of
food end of energy they can put them in
the market
on the other hand
restrictions need to be abolished
[Music]
namely export restrictions
there should be no hoarding of
any of these products but
most important and everything else
we need to use immediately the financial
instruments that are available i've been
saying many times that our global
financial system is morally bankrupt
i've been saying many times that we need
a deep reform in the global financial
system but now it's a matter of
emergency is to use the instruments that
are there and need to be mobilized and i
count on
political will and we have established
as i said mechanisms to mobilize as much
as we can the political leaders in
relation to these objectives
now the second um
question was
in related to the
um
the
the the wars
and so
um
martin griffith went to moscow and kiev
uh
i don't think we have a chance to have a
humanitarian ceasefire as we wanted
globally
but
there is a number of proposals that were
made
and we are waiting uh for an answer uh
from the russian federation in relation
to those proposals uh
including different mechanisms for local
ceasefires for corridors for
humanitarian assistance evacuations and
different other aspects that can
minimize the dramatic impact on
civilians that we are witnessing
and
i believe that
you mentioned a statement in which it
was said that
the peace negotiations were dead
i would remind you that we are in an
easter period
and the easter period is about
resurrection
newspaper i have two questions first to
the secretary general you have been
sounding the alarm a lot of times about
different issues the ones you talk today
about but and there's a lot of promises
that world leaders are
saying but they are not delivering so my
question to you what's your plan b uh to
uh to put more pressure on these world
leaders and
my question uh
to miss uh
grinspan is about
trade and women empowerment
and
if you to which to what extent are
influenced countries committed to
empowering women in trade giving the
fact that trade is extremely important
also to
the issues you talked about thank you
plan b is never to give up on the plan a
because nothing can replace the
political will that is needed for these
decisions to be taken
we can say what is needed
the resources are available we need
political decisions so the plan b
is to insist on the plan a for these
political decisions to be taken by those
that have the capacity to do it
thank you michelle
no no that is a question i'm sorry
rebecca
yeah
women trade very important yes we are
really working very hard with women
traders and the empowerment of women
especially in it rate yes and for them
it's very important not to have
restrictions because the restrictions
hurt women the most they cannot you know
really find any other ways and means
you know of of a for for for the
earnings of their families so you are
right even in the crisis we have to
insist
in trade and women power empowerment and
trade
thank you michelle
thank you thank you for the very thing
um
first of all a question on the on the
report were uh sanctions that have been
imposed in the wake of the russian
invasion of ukraine were they taken into
consideration um when pulling together
this report and secretary general
could you just clarify what you told us
about um the un push for a humanitarian
ceasefire you're saying that you don't
see a possibility at the moment for a
humanitarian ceasefire in ukraine and
what are the suggestions you
have made to russia um and if you could
get president putin on the phone what
would you say to him
well
we have taken into account all the facts
it's very difficult to be able to say
what is what what we have put together
is objectively what are the impacts and
the exposures from all what is happening
because of the war in ukraine
so everything is being taken into
account because the figures
reflect the objective impacts that they
are having
everywhere
well uh a global ceasefire at the
present moment doesn't seem to be um
possible
but there are lots of things that can be
done in order to guarantee evacuation of
civilians from areas of fighting in
order of guaranteeing humanitarian
access
in in a reliable situation
and
we also propose the the creation of a
mechanism involving the
russian federation the ukraine and
the u.n and eventually other
humanitarian entities in order to have a
cell to permanently together manage and
avoid incidents in this kind of
situations we have had
a number of
uh moments in which it was said that
there was a local ceasefire and that
things would happen and then things did
not happen and then everybody accuses
everybody of everything instead of
this what we need is to bring the
parties together and to manage together
situations like these to make sure that
we have adequate equations to make sure
that we have adequate humanitarian
access to the populations in it
the the putin
i mean the most important message is
that
we need to silence the guns and we need
to have a serious negotiation to achieve
peace
you you referenced a global ceasefire do
you mean a ceasefire in ukraine is not
possible
at the present moment a global ceasefire
in ukraine
in ukraine doesn't seem possible
that was our appeal for humanitarian
reasons but it doesn't seem possible
petroleum thank you mr secretary general
beats
uh with western nations supporting
ukraine and china taking side with
russia do you think the world is going
into another cold war and uh how do you
think this war will reshape the future
of the international order thank you
well i i'm not sure that things are
exactly as you described but
i would say that at the present moment
i want everybody united in relation to
support the people in need
we'll talk about international order
afterwards
now we have people in desperate need in
many parts of the world they are not
interested in knowing what is the future
of multilateralism they are interested
in having the financial support and the
support in relation to the food and
energy crisis that they require
afterwards there will be a very
interesting and important discussion and
i think our common agenda is about it
how we can strengthen multilateralism
and avoid the kind of divisions that you
mentioned
showing bryce peace south african
broadcast thanks jeff thank you sg mrs
greenspan my question is going to be for
the deputy secretary general
who hasn't said a word during this
briefing dsg
let's talk particularly about
sub-saharan africa region you are very
familiar with what are the implications
of this report if they are not
implemented in terms of these
recommendations what are the
implications for a region where the sg
has talked about coups being back you
have staggeringly high youth
unemployment uh political instability
where it's very easy to break the camels
back what are the risks here for africa
sub-saharan africa in particular
uh thank you sherwin for reminding me i
kept quiet for once
[Laughter]
now this is very serious for sub-saharan
africa and given the context that we see
there it's more than just the conflicts
it's also the climate crisis
so this uh multitude of crises that are
happening um in the region this report
gives us again the solutions to acting
now with the instruments that we have
otherwise there will be even more
instability there will be even more
crisis as we see it and that crisis will
go beyond borders
um so so for us when you hear rebecca
talking about the 69 that is severe all
three um you know this is this is what
sub-saharan africa will be
um prone to but right now we we have the
countries that are just one crisis we
need to prevent that one from becoming
this free um on food and energy and on
the financing uh so solutions here there
are immediate meetings where actions can
be taken
the sg's champions group are voices of
leaders who can convince their
colleagues to take these actions where
they can um and and for us it's about
making sure those those recommendations
are are practical they're doable and
they are taken to the sense of urgency
uh leicester uh you know what the
fallout of this becomes one of several
um you know billion people it's over a
billion in africa but it will go beyond
the borders
thank you
greg
with severe
or significant exposure
to this crisis i'm talking about the
most dramatically impacted
countries we have 25 countries in africa
now
the the risks
for the african continent and for
peace and stability in the african
continent beyond the risks for hunger
and poverty of the african people are
now
extraordinarily
in expanded
and
we have uh of course a particular
concern about africa in which the depth
sector journal has been leading we have
a process of developing
a comprehensive strategy for the african
continent more in general
but
in relation to this crisis africa is
particularly targeted
gregory uh tas news agency
uh thank you very much uh secretary
general um are you wondering given the
fact
that the world food program has learned
about the hunger on 2020 and the last
year wise group is creating only right
now and
some experts
told
consider this current food and energy
crisis as a result of lack of investment
in traditional source of energy
and so
uh
given these facts uh what do you think
how
uh
the pace and methods of uh
how how this current crisis can affect
on the pace and methods on the
climate change response in relation to
your first question
since
if you look at the reports
you see that the prices of food and the
prices of energy have been climbing
what we have now is an acceleration
if you look at
page 1 of the report
you see that
for an index 100 of
the fao
food price index
in 2019
we came to the end of 2021 with an index
of 130
so food prices were already climbing
and we came now to an index of 160.
there is a clear acceleration so
obviously the food and energy prices
were already on the rise we had
inflation already on the rise what we
have now is a dramatic impact of
acceleration
now
i think there was a lack of investment
but in renewable energy
if we had invested much more seriously
in the last 10 20 years in renewable
energy
would not be dependent on the
permanent fluctuations in the markets in
relation to
fossil fuels
the fact that countries have not enough
renewable energy which is
based on self-reliance uh makes them
much more dependent on markets and
markets have always been extremely
volatile and so
my answer is there is indeed there has
been indeed lack of investment in the
recent decades but
mostly i believe lack of investment in
renewable energies and there were many
interests
that of course were opposing that
investment and that is probably the
reason why it has been so slow and that
is reason why now we see countries
rushing to
understand that
we need a world much less dependent on
resources that
cannot be uh replaced i mean that one
they will be exhausted
i'm fox cbs news
thank you so much so follow up for um
dsg uh muhammad from sherwin's question
you mentioned world leaders
who's on board with this i mean in terms
of
the grand assistance we've seen numbers
but how much is that
um coming how much are people actually
paying their pledges
um and then to the 2sgs
um
and maybe you can answer this too how
much i are the ifis on board you i've
i've gotten through most of the report
and you said yeah the um imf the world
bank are they signed on and has there
been any
consideration of alternate currencies
cryptocurrencies things like that
um just curious thank you
thank you well i mean you you can see
from the the voices that we have of of
those in support from the six world
leaders that the sg's talked about and
having the the presidency of the g20 is
not a small uh
leadership in involved in that right now
what we're seeing is that the resources
are not going towards um stemming the
tide of this um of this crisis and
that's what we need to see that it does
we don't see oda go into military
expenditure but that we see that it's
additional if it's to protect lives and
that we need um you know to keep the oda
to keep the foreign direct investment to
keep all the tools that we have existing
that rebecca has talked about um in play
um it's uh let's see what happens in the
spring meetings because the spring
meetings are an important signal um as
to whether this crisis is going to be
taken seriously or not it's doable um it
is immediate um and it will it will send
the signals um of the the uh the
engagement and the traction for wanting
uh to avoid a global crisis and that's
what we're trying to do um right now
we are obviously we are obviously we are
obviously in permanent consultation with
the mf and world bank but
the imf and world bank um
people
like the u.n secretariat
they depend the one secretary depends on
the security council and the general
assembly and the imf
leaders
depends on their boards and what we need
now is the boards of the institutions
and in general
those that have power to act uh allowing
for instruments that are available we
are not suggesting anything
new we are only suggesting that
instruments that are available to be
effectively put in action okay can i
also just can i also just add that it's
not just the imf and the world bank we
also have the heads of all the regional
development banks and this is important
because this is going to happen in every
region and country in the world and so
having them on board as well has been
very helpful and they have been working
with rebecca in the task team
mario velar
mario velar
a question on energy perhaps for uh miss
grinspin in the recommendations of the
uh report you uh support targeted relief
for people that can't afford fuel right
now given the high prices but you ask
that the support isn't allocated
universally which is what some countries
are doing right now for example in
western europe uh reducing the price of
gasoline for consumers can you elaborate
on why this is a bad idea
yeah uh
we understand that people need
support right now
but they we would like
the support to be targeted
and not universal subsidies
to
fossil fuels because
they are very different difficult to
then
take away
and they will
a preclude
to really accelerate the transition
towards renewable energy and new
and clean forms of energy
so we already have a
many experiences on this yes we know
what universal subsidies do
and we know also how effective can be
when you have a good system that is
designed to help the people that needs
to have access to energy that is a much
better way to do it right now
mate this
impact this
report
is targeted at developing countries
and
some countries some developed countries
have fiscal space to do whatever they
want
but there are many developing countries
that simply have no physical space
to use universal instruments and that
need to be able to use the very narrow
fiscal space to support the most
vulnerable people
so i think it's important to see that
there are completely different
perspectives i was
prime minister of a country
and i know what it is
to act when there is physical space and
what it is
to act when there is no physical space
it's completely different
linda fasulo
um this question is with mr secretary
general you discussed the severe food
crisis around the world particularly in
the poor countries i was wondering if
the un has a policy in terms of buying
purchasing food and energy from russia
to provide humanitarian aid to the poor
countries and also since the un is a
great proponent of targeted sanctions i
mean at least when of course there are
u.n sanctions
do you have a view or i don't know what
the status is in terms of
russian people in terms of russia being
able to buy
humanitarian supplies whether it's
medical supplies or anything else
of course we are concerned with the
needs of vulnerable people everywhere
and in relation to the procurement
policy of the world food program the
procurement policy of the world food
programme is based on its rules and
it is done
we all recognize that
it is done in the best possible way
unfortunately the world food program was
buying 50 percent of its food from the
ukraine and there is no way you can take
those 50 out of ukraine at the present
moment
linda
oh sorry
mr secretary general
what do you say to you talked about
africa earlier
what do you say to african countries
that are saying
the war in ukraine is not our war
but we are going to pay a high price
we say to them
that
the war in ukraine affects everybody so
it's also their war
but uh
i have to say that i understand the
grievances of those that in many moments
felt there was no international
solidarity with them
so the best way is simultaneously
to make developed world understand
that it's important to support
developing world in times in need
for developing world also to be able
to assume
that
the situation like the war in ukraine is
also their situation
last question
afp which is
we need global solidarity in all
directions
thank you
question from mr gutierrez do you see a
genocide ongoing in ukraine
well uh
genocide
is strictly defined in international law
and for the u.n uh we rely
on
final legal determination by appropriate
judicial bodies
so we are
deeply concerned with violations of
human rights i've been saying it time
and time again we are deeply concerned
with the
the dramatic impact of the conflict in
these regards but
we live the definition of whether there
is or not a situation of genocide to the
judicial bodies that are relevant in
this regard and by the way there is an
investigation of the international
criminal court taking place in ukraine
at the present moment
thank you thank you very much thank you
missions
foreign
is
is
for generations statement and i now give
the floor to the representative of kenya
thank you mr president
it is particularly fitting that
lord ahmad
should have chaired this debate earlier
uh given his role as the prime
minister's
special representative on preventing
sexual violence in conflict we thank you
delegation for bringing this important
debate to the council
i also thank srsg pramila patton and the
other briefers for their insights
ms nadia murad
thank you very much for your
extraordinary bravery
and determination and service to the
yazidi people
to women
and to all humanity
with what you're doing
kenya strongly condemns
gender-based violence and its
manifestation in all contexts and as it
takes place in the brutality and
inhumanity
of the conflicts in syria ukraine
ethiopia and other wars
mr president war itself is the crime
that opens the door to the kinds of war
crimes we're discussing today
war even when it purports the opposite
and particularly when it's prolonged
almost inevitably leads to the breakdown
of law
order and moral conscience
we must redouble our efforts to prevent
and stop war
we must be rid of the illusions of
limited or precision precision guided
war
which in the last 20 years have shown
their serious limits
we must turn our knowledge and
experience of mediation to innovation
and boldness of vision to stop the
present wars
thank you helena behanu for your words
and recommendations
to the a3 and to the african union
we hear and feel the pain
of the ethiopian people
and especially the suffering of the
people of tigre
we urge for cooperation and openness to
mediation that enables full humanitarian
access ceasefire and eventually to peace
with justice
in the last year the a3 has sought to
stand with the people of ethiopia
as brother has taken arms against
brother
and we will continue to do so
we have spoken up with strong
recommendations we have embraced the
democratic aspirations of your country
we have urged humanitarian access and
pushed for the council's support for
african union and regional mediation
the a3 ones in this chamber
urged for ceasefire observing that there
is no lasting victory in crushing one's
countrymen and country women
i know this is still the position of the
a3
as your neighbors and your brothers and
sisters
we urge you on to embrace one another
to get beyond the intense suffering and
pain that you're causing each other
and to reach for the peace that we all
pray and hope for you
mr president we're here in search of
implementing commitments and existing
frameworks
kenya is a country enacted has enacted
strong laws and policies to combat
sexual and gender-based violence
and we will champion the efforts in this
chamber and outside it
to continue to do so
our focus for today is on sexual
violence perpetrated by terrorist groups
the secretary general's current report
on conflict-related sexual violence
underscores once again how sexual
violence continues to be a tactic of war
and terrorism
we are concerned that there is too
little effort to ensure accountability
for sexual violence perpetrated by
terrorists
the security council should undertake
strong efforts to list those responsible
including their chains of command
it should call for cases
of sexual violence to also
to be prosecuted within the context of
terrorism
this should include the recommendation
by ms mariana
kakutly on sexual violence in prisons
we urge in that regard that the security
council takes steps to list and sanction
administrators of prisons and their
chain of command if their facilities are
party to systemic and systematic sexual
violence against prisoners
mr president i'll propose three areas of
action that i hope offer further
opportunities for practical
implementation
first on member states responsibility
states must escalate prosecution for
gender-based violence and enhance
efforts in preventing and responding to
conflict-related sexual violence
all effort must be put to address
stigmatization
discriminatory laws and other cultural
barriers that stand in the way of
reporting and accountability
these should be reinforced by gender
responsive and inclusive national
security sector
and the needed reforms to achieve it
accountability and prevention demands
localized identification of gaps and
a communal and that communal
infrastructure be operationalized for
social awareness and sensitization
programs as well as access to justice
mechanisms and medical and psychological
care to the victims of sexual and
gender-based violence
secondly on the role of the security
council
we note that the current report
underlines
that the series of cancer resolutions
has helped to raise the cost of what has
long been perceived as the cheapest and
oldest weapon of war
we believe that the bar should be even
higher there is an urgent move to move
need to move from commitment to
compliance from resolutions to results
beyond listings and incorporation of
sgbv as a separate listing criterion in
the relevant sanctions regimes the
council should also take specific steps
and deterrent measures to also increase
the costs of acts of conflict-related
sexual violence
stronger integration and investment in
the wps counterterrorism and countering
violent extremism agendas
will also contribute to increase the
cost of those atrocities
for example the implementation of
resolution 22 42 of 2015 which
recognizes the acts of sexual and
gender-based violence are part of the
strategic objectives and ideology of
certain terrorist groups including
al-qaeda isis al-shabab and boko haram
should be linked to other resolutions
that touch on countering terrorism
including 23 54 21 78 and 23 31.
third
on cross-border corporation the
intersecting elements of rising
militarization coup d'etat
and conflicts with a transnational
character
call for enhanced coordinated action
especially where such contexts lead to
increased refugee and idp situations
with potential aggravation of
conflict-related sexual violence and
human trafficking
we call for more effective cross-border
coordination between border security
personnel early warning mechanisms
national and regional women's protection
advisors and humanitarian actors
to minimize prevention and reporting
gaps in alignment resolution 2467
of
2019 that speaks to cross-border
dynamics
given the importance of this
cross-border and regional coordination
kenya supports strategies for advancing
implementation of the mandate and the
integration of women peace and wps
positions into the un annual budgets of
peace operations particularly during
transition processes in line with
resolution 25 94.
in this regard kenya looks forward to
srsg patton's launch of her report
in june
we also look forward to the
international adoption of the murad code
i thank you
i thank the representative of kenya for
their statements
now now i now give the floor to her
excellency was marta lucia ramirez vice
president and minister for foreign
affairs of colombia
everyone
yes
together
you don't have to be a victim
multilateral
[Music]
no
[Music]
is
it
is
at this time
[Music]
foreign
is
is
is
foreign
a
is
is
is
now let me remind all speakers to uh
limit their statements to no more than
four minutes we are running a tight with
time um but i now give the floor uh to
the representative of jordan
thank you mr president distinguished
colleagues allow me at the outset to
congratulate you on the uk's presidency
of the united nations security council
uh for the month of april
and thank you for convening this timely
meeting to discuss conflict-related
sexual violence
i would like to thank the distinguished
briefers for their invaluable
service to the cause of combating
conflict related sexual violence and
their contribution to the debate today
mr president covert 19 has exasperated
violence against women and girls
especially those in conflict
conflict-related sexual violence is a
tactic used
often to target civilians inflicting
long-term trauma and humiliation
fracturing families and the social
fabric
triggering displacement and fueling and
actors activities
uh throughout the years the role of
peacekeeping missions has evolved and
been modernized to adapt to new emerging
challenges
such as the crsv
a coordinated and comprehensive approach
across civilian military
and police components from strategic to
operational levels is critical for to
peacekeeping missions
to effectively prevent and respond to
in
crsv
performance of their mandates training
mainstreaming policies against crsp
enhancing monitoring
and reporting mechanisms and advocacy
and raising awareness are crucial
elements in any successful strategy
strategy to combat crsv
distinguished colleagues jordan a host
country of
two millions of refugees
had its already scarce resources
strained nonetheless through its
response plan
we carried numerous outreach activities
uh that have the objective of raising
awareness particularly among young
people to change social norms and
promote
gender equality with a particular focus
on the prevention of child marriage and
ending sexual and gender-based violence
in addition
jordan's yps 2250
national coalition has collaborated with
unfpa to organize an online interactive
session to mobilize young people and
representatives of youth organizations
and networks on crsv
and discuss the impact of sexual
violence on the lives of young people
and their com communities
as well as the effective tools to combat
the phenomena
gender responsive security sector
reforms remain crucial for the
fulfillment of our mission to eliminate
crsv
as part of jordan's national action plan
we managed to integrate gender
responsive training into the security
sector
mr president
we must ensure that existing un
international and national mechanisms to
combat sexual violence are supported and
provided with the needed resources
to support survivors and prevent future
tragedies
perpetrators of violence
whether state or non-state actors
must also be held responsible for their
acts
states should harmonize their
legislation to criminalize crsv
under the national laws and remove any
procedural impediments for prosecution
of the crimes
including
forms of immunity like immunity racione
materia
crsp must not be seen as an inevitable
byproduct of the process
effective implementation of criminal
responsibility
criminal accountability and
international responsibility is an
important deterrent for the commission
from the commission of the crime
the well-being of survivors should be
our focus in the efforts to reducing and
preventing sexual violence
ensuring equal access to medical care
and psychological support for all sexual
violence survivors during conflict and
in post-conflict situation situations is
an integral part of the process
distinguished colleagues now is the
moment to enhance our joint efforts to
eliminate sexual violence in conflicts
we have a second chance to reset the
rhythm in our endeavors to end conflicts
around the world and build back better
for our future generations where every
individual around the world would a bit
be able to realize their full potential
thank you
i thank the representative of jordan for
their statement and i give the floor to
the representative of malta
mr president i begin by thanking the uk
for organizing this open debate and
today's brief is for enriching the
discussion with our personal experiences
and insights
malta aligns itself with the statements
to be delivered by the european union
and the group of friends of
of women peace and security and the
lgbti core group and would like to make
some additional remarks in its national
capacity
mr president
sexual violence and rape are terrifying
weapons of war aimed at humiliating and
stigmatizing helpless civilians
as members of the international
community we must strive to prevent
these crimes redouble our efforts to
hold perpetrators accountable and ensure
that we support survivors
we must reject the notion that sexual
violence and rape are unfortunate but
inevitable consequences of war they are
not
they are war crimes
they are a breach of international law
and must be treated as such
in ukraine reports of rape continue to
increase several women and girls have
recounted the sexual violence and abuse
that they have suffered at the hands of
russian soldiers i commend the courage
of the many women who are sharing the
chilling accounts of rape and other
forms of sexual violence
what we are hearing by word of mouth
especially of survivors is horrific
we cannot be silent in the face of such
atrocities neither can we forget what
has happened and continues to happen in
other parts of the world in syria yemen
south sudan nigeria
democratic republic of congo afghanistan
iraq ethiopia myanmar libya and other
places
malta is concerned that children
particularly girls and vulnerable are
vulnerable to sexual violence at or on
their way to school we call on all
parties to conflict to end and prevent
sexual violence against children
mr president conflict-related sexual
violence is equally traumatizing yet
different in nuance for women girls men
boys and people with diverse sexual
orientation gender identity or
expression and sex characteristics
justice and accountability must be
crucial parts of our response
and more awareness is needed to promote
accountability
survivors must be kept at the center of
our efforts
they must have access to resources to
counter the multiple and intersecting
forms of the screen of discrimination
they face
while a more gendered psychological and
medical support should be ensured
special representative patton has once
again pointed out to the fear and stigma
that survivors face
motor fully supports the mandate of srsg
and commends the important work of her
office
it is equally important for women and
girls in order diversity to enjoy full
equal and meaningful participation and
leadership at all levels of decision
making as outlined in security council
resolution 1325
providing all survivors with access to a
holistic model of care covering medical
psychological legal and socio-economic
needs is a concrete way to empower women
towards demanding their rights and
creating change both within their
countries and globally
there can be no impunity for those who
violate human rights law and
international humanitarian law the icc
can contribute to the fight against
conflict-related sexual violence
by developing and consolidating a
gender-responsive legal framework and
jurisprudence
the capacity of governments judiciary
police military and civil society should
be further built to gather evidence and
strengthen prosecutions
training to military and police
personnel peacekeepers grassroots
organizations and human rights offenders
on sexual violence issues remains
essential
in conclusion by adopting a holistic
approach we need to save and protect but
also we hope that victims given all the
support for their recovery are
transformed into empowered survivors and
agents of change within their
communities thank
you i thank the representative of malta
for her statement and i give the floor
to the representative of canada
thank you very much mr president i speak
on behalf from 64 member states of the
group of friends of women peace and
security
our group is profoundly concerned by the
persistent and widespread
use of sexual violence with impunity by
state and non-state actors in a great
many conflicts around the world
the list of these conflicts is long mr
president and it's been mentioned by
several including in the secretary
general's report
i think it's important that we bear them
all in mind
i appreciated the comments from my
colleague from malta with respect to the
situation in ukraine
and we need to understand that the u.n
high commissioner for human rights has
spoken of possible war crimes breaches
of international humanitarian law and
serious violations of international
human rights laws
we strongly support the secretary
general's call for an immediate
independent investigation of the conduct
of all those involved in the conflict
mr president we call on all parties in
all conflict situations to immediately
cease all forms of sexual violence
consistent with international law and
with resolutions of the security council
those responsibles for such heinous acts
must be held to account by national
justice or where that is not possible
international justice
regrettably for many victims and
survivors access to justice remedies and
reparation
is non-existent or painfully slow
u.n member states must fight impunity
through strengthening the rule of law
our group strongly encourages the
security council to incorporate and
apply sexual violence as a designation
criterion in u.n sanctioned regimes
we must redouble our efforts to
dismantle all barriers that hinder
survivors from safely reporting sexual
violence and from access accessing
essential services which includes sexual
and reproductive health care services
victim advocacy
mental health and social psychosocial
support and legal services we also
reiterate the importance of ensuring
universal access
to sexual reproductive health and
reproductive rights as has been agreed
in accordance with the program of action
of the international conference on
population and development as well as
the beijing platform for action
we call on all parties to ensure a safe
and enabling environment for civil
society including women peace builders
women human rights defenders to carry
out their important work free of
intimidation free from violence and free
from reprisals
mr president member states must invest
in tackling the root causes of
conflict-related violence
prevention starts we believe with a
commitment first of all
and foremost to gender equality
with the empowerment of women and girls
in diverse situations and conditions
the protection and promotion of human
rights and women's full equal and
meaningful participation and leadership
at all levels of decision
we encourage the council to ensure that
country mandates emphasize the
prevention of conflict-related sexual
violence and strengthen early warning
systems through the deployment of
women's protection advisors
finally it is critical that survivors
remain at the heart of all of our
efforts we must recognize that survivors
have different needs and may face
multiple intersecting forms of
discrimination we must ensure that their
rights are respected that they're
treated with dignity that they're able
to access justice and that they can
safely fully and meaningfully
participate in decision making at all
levels
canada
accountability
[Music]
i had the opportunity to serve as the
prime minister's special envoy to
myanmar and to bangladesh
i came to the camp in cox's bazar
three or four weeks after the forcible
deportation of nearly a million people
many of them women and girls most of
them women and girls i had the
opportunity to speak to a great many
women who had been the victims
of sexual violence sexual violence is
not about sex it's about power
and it's about violence
and it's about the abuse of patriarchal
power
the stories that i heard have been
repeated and luckily fortunately have
people have been able to tell them to a
great many people who have gathered
evidence and who are gathering evidence
and presenting this evidence
tragically this experience is going to
have to be repeated in country after
country after country
we have to take every possible step to
stop this terrible abuse thank you mr
president
i thank the representative of canada
for his statements there are still a
number of speakers remaining on my list
for this meeting so i intend with the
concurrence of members of the council to
suspend the meeting in until 3 p.m
and i also thank the interpreters for
keeping going until this time
the meeting is suspended
thank you very much thank you for your
time
yes
okay
is
okay
wait
so far so good um
anyways
it just seems like everything's gonna
work
do this
oh
easy
oh
okay
you